ERIC LEICHTENSCHLAG: Hello.
I'm Eric Leichtenschlag with the
Google developer relations
team for AdMob.
Today I will walk through how
to get started with the ad
catalog for Android, a sample
project that demonstrates how
to incorporate ads into your
Android application.
The requirements for this sample
project are an Android
SDK, version 3.2 or higher,
the Google AdMob SDK for
Android, and an AdMob
publisher ID.
This walkthrough will also
be used in the Eclipse
development environment.
It is assumed that you have
the Eclipse development
environment, as well
as the Android SDK,
installed on your machine.
The first thing we
need to do is
download the sample project.
You can find it at
code.google.com/
p/google-mobile-dev. From here,
click on the Downloads
tab and find the most recent
version of the
ad catalog for Android.
Now download the zip file
to your file system.
The next thing we will
need is the Google
AdMob SDK for Android.
You can find this by going to
code.google.com/mobile/ads.
From here, click on the Download
tab and find the most
recent version of the
Google AdMob SDK.
Now download this SDK
to your file system.
Now that we have both zip files,
we can extract them to
a directory of our choosing.
For simplicity, I will extract
both the zip files to the
downloads directory.
The next step is to add the ad
catalog project into Eclipse.
Remember the assumption that
you need both the Eclipse
development environment, as
well as an Android SDK,
version 3.2 or higher,
pre-installed on your machine.
To add the project, go to File,
New, Project, Android
Project, Create project
from existing source.
From here, you can browse to
the location of your ad
catalog project and
click Open.
Now we need to set
the build target.
We have to set the build target
to an Android SDK,
version 3.2 or higher.
Now click Finish.
Now we need to add the Google
AdMob SDK to the project.
To do this, we can right click
the project and go to
Properties.
From here, click on Java
Build Path and then
Add External JARs.
Browse to the directory where
you downloaded the
Google AdMob SDK.
Now select Open, and
finally hit OK.
The last thing we will need is
an AdMob publisher ID to add
to our sample project.
You can find one by going
to www.admob.com.
Create an account if you
don't already have one.
Once you do, go to Marketplace,
Sites & Apps, and
Add Site or App.
Now you can create an Android
application by filling out the
form below.
It is OK to leave out the
market URL at this time.
When creating a site or app for
your own project, you can
leave this field blank and add
it later once your project
goes into the market.
Once you fill out the form,
click Continue.
After adding your site or
app, go back to the
Sites & Apps page.
And under the site or app you
just created, click Manage
Settings and find your
AdMob publisher ID.
Copy your AdMob publisher ID
so you can use it in your
sample project.
Now that you have your publisher
ID, you can add it
to the project by navigating to
res, values, strings.xml.
From here, find the string
admob_id and replace it with
your AdMob publisher ID.
Remember not to leave any
trailing white space, as this
will affect the publisher
ID value.
Now click Save.
We are now ready to
run the project.
But first, let's look at what
versions of Android are
compatible with the project.
By looking at the user's SDK
element, we can see that the
Android minSdkVersion is 4,
meaning that we can run the
project on any device version
1.6 or higher.
Now, let's select a compatible
emulator for the project.
You will want to create
a new AVD if you don't
already have one.
I will use the Froyo-hdpi AVD,
which will run Android 2.2
with API level 8.
Now, click Start and wait for
the emulator to load.
Once the emulator finishes
loading, we can run the
project by clicking
on the Run icon.
Select the AVD that we started
up earlier to run the project.
Then click OK.
That's it.
We now have the ad
catalog project
running on the emulator.
Feel free to check out our
different use cases for banner
and interstitial ads in
the existing project.
In the next version, we plan to
focus on best practices for
incorporating banner ads into
different layouts, such as
inside a scrolling view
or a tab view.
Here are some useful links for
more information about the
Google AdMob SDK.
For help getting started, check
out the documentation.
For questions about the ad
catalog or the Google AdMob
SDK, check out our forum.
For news updates and release
announcements,
check out our blog.
And finally, for updates to
the ad catalog and other
sample projects, check out
our code example page.
Thank you for your time and
enjoy using the ad catalog.